For our experts interview.
We'll have the honor of speaking with Dr. David Pizarro and associate professor
of psychology at Cornell University.
Dr Pizarro is a leading figure in morality and emotion.
His research interests are in moral judgment and the effects of emotion on
judgment.
He received his phd from Yale University and has received research grants from
the National Science Foundation and was a summer fellow at the center for the
advanced study in the behavioral sciences.
He's also given a wide the acclaim Ted talk on the strange politics of
discussed.
So I'm pleased today to be speaking with Dr. David Pizarro on morality and
Hi David.
Thanks for speaking with us today.
Thank you,
June.
So we're all curious,
what got you first interested in emotion in the first place,
sort of where did it all begin?
The honest truth is that I was interested in moral and ethical judgment first
and I really,
really wanted him to study moral psychology.
But that was at a time when it wasn't a very popular topic,
uh,
especially within social psychology,
which is what I had started studying.
But I realized that if I studied emotion,
a lot of work in social psychology had to do with emotion and its influence on
behavior and some of that work was on its influence on altruism and prosocial
behavior.
Uh,
so because emotion had this deep link to morality already,
both from old school philosophy and in more modern social psychology,
I decided,
well,
okay,
well also study emotion.
Just as a way I kind of is a sneaky way to study morality,
but I came to love it on its own as I hope is evident.
So being a sneak star then I want to ask you a few questions about your
research.
So,
um,
you studied discuss,
I know most of us can all things think about things that like did really
discussed us in everyday life.
I know I'm pretty disgust sensitive and I think you might be too.
Barry Barry Disgust sensitive problem.
Actually hard to do research.
Yes.
Can you tell me what is discussed really?
Like why do we have it in the first place?
Uh,
that's,
that's the million dollar question,
isn't it?
Disgust is,
um,
what many would call a basic universal emotion that is no matter where you look,
it appears that people across the world habit,
it emerges fairly early on in life.
And it seems to be an emotion that's dedicated to a pretty specific function.
And that function is to keep you away from eating or touching things that might
make you sick.
So even the word disgust betrays the origins,
uh,
that the gust part refers to the tastes function.
And for instance,
if you give little babies are really bitter sour taste.
They make a very similar face to what we make when we had discussed it as
adults.
So the thinking is that disgust is an emotion that evolved really to keep us
away from,
from what we now consider gross things.
But,
but what we say when we say gross things,
we really mean things that are dangerous because of their possible possible
contamination.
So then are there things that discussed all humans universally or does it seem
to very cross culturally?
Yes.
So disgust.
Disgust is a great emotion because the list of things that seem to discuss
people universally is pretty robust.
And so when no matter really where you look across the world with some
exceptions,
people don't like things like pus and feces and Al Roker rotten meat,
at least I haven't encountered any culture that eats puss on a regular basis as
a delicacy.
See this,
this actually shows you another feature of discuss how easy it is to engender a
disgusting,
especially people like us.
But that's not to say just because as you is emotion researchers,
we loved the universal part.
So the list for discussed seems pretty,
pretty big and robust,
but the list of culturally variable disgust,
you listed her as those things that make us,
he's lead disgusting,
uh,
is actually much larger.
So,
um,
I'll give you an example.
For Chinese people,
the fact that we eat cheese is pretty gross.
So they,
they,
they're,
they're going to ask us questions like,
wait,
you wait until the milk gets rotten.
And then you wait until it curdles up into solid balls and you combine those
together and you eat them.
And to them that's just utterly disgusting of course to us.
Many of the things that,
uh,
that people eat in mainland China might be disgusting and that reaction is just
as powerful,
but it is culturally variable.
And one reason that it kind of has to be culturally variable is that we grew up
in different environments,
different,
different places and we're required as children to eat different things.
It would be very bad for,
for us to have such a rigid disgust response that even as infants we rejected
everything.
So there's a huge variety of things that we can learn to eat and not be
disgusted by.
What's really cool about the work you've done on discussed too is that you show,
it's not just,
you know,
uh,
designed to sort of expel,
you know,
nasty curdles and cheese balls or you know,
whatever,
whatever your thing is,
but that it actually also can influence,
you've shown like higher order moral reasoning such as,
you know,
attitudes about homosexuality or political affiliation and how is it possible
that discuss can influence these kinds of more complex attitudes.
Okay.
Yeah.
So that was a puzzle to us because it really does seem like disgust ought to be
constrained to just those things that might make you sick.
The problem is nowadays we have all kinds of information about what really is
dangerous and what really isn't.
So we know,
for instance,
we have a proper germ theory of disease.
We know that,
uh,
shaking someone's hand won't give us HIV for instance.
Um,
discussed as the emotion,
didn't really know that.
And so the story that,
that,
uh,
I believe about how disgust evolved and many others who studied,
discussed,
believe this is that discussed sort of spread from not just keeping us from
eating bad things but also from anything that might be potentially
contaminating.
But what happens is that people are one big source of pathogens for us.
And so anybody who encounters a stranger whom they have never encountered
before,
um,
is running the risk that they're going to carry diseases that we don't have
immunity for.
And so it behooves us to have this emotion that,
that actually would keep us away from,
uh,
from coming into close contact with especially people who look sick.
So any marker that you might have a disease,
like an infection.
One of the disgust solicitors that I use very reliably is I have a friend who's
a dermatologist and she gave me access to this data,
Bank of,
of skin diseases,
just skin.
These are like a big warning sign,
like stay away from me because you,
this might happen to your skin.
And uh,
and so because discussed as these features,
one,
it's really,
really easy to elicit.
All right.
You know,
as you,
as you know in his other people who you're gonna interview know,
sometimes it's really hard to bring people in for the lab and actually discuss
them.
Um,
so it's really easy to elicit,
uh,
it,
it can easily be tagged to people because people are a potential source of
pathogens.
So now what you have is an emotional system that's biased toward rejecting and
avoiding individuals.
And sometimes even groups that might either appear diseased or might have any
sort of difference in their hygiene,
in their cleanliness,
customs in there,
in the food that they eat or even in their sexual behavior.
Um,
and it turns out that sex is quite easily linked to disgust.
I don't think I need to go into an exam.
Any examples about that?
Um,
but in the sexual domain is one that lends itself very nicely.
So a lot of the work on discussed has been around,
uh,
it's,
it's it function and preventing us from,
from engaging in incest.
Um,
so that's a good thing.
And so,
so now you have an emotion that can easily be linked to individuals or groups,
especially ones that are different who are different from us.
And it makes sense that it would be a very powerful emotion if what you're
trying to do is convince somebody else that,
for instance,
homosexual behaviors is wrong.
Right?
It gives you that powerful gut reaction that,
oh,
that's gross.
That's something that I don't do.
Um,
and,
and therefore it's wrong.
So do you think that this is a special feature of discuss that it's a special
emotion that can,
you know,
influence our moral judgments?
Or are there other emotions that share these kind of similar features as
discussed?
You know,
when it comes down to it,
if you,
if you really as somebody who studies morality,
if what I really want to do is try to explain all of human moral judgment,
discuss,
there's only going to play a small role.
All emotions have this power to influence,
to influence judgment broadly and moral judgment in particular discussed has uh,
it appears to have a very specific tie to,
to human morality that some of the other ones don't.
But um,
but when you look at it,
some of some of the emotions,
some of our social emotions for instance,
like anger and sympathy or empathy,
those are kind of tailor made for,
for our social relations and something that we might refer to as ethical
judgment.
So for instance,
when you're angry at somebody,
it often contains this element of blame that they did something that they should
not have done.
And I want justice or revenge.
Disgust.
Disgust is interesting in that even though it might only affect a small bit of
our moral judgments,
it isn't,
it's proper domain doesn't seem to be moral evaluation in the same way that
anger or sympathy might be.
Sympathy seems like it was built to make us care about other people.
Anger seems like it was built to,
to keep others from cheating.
US discussed seems to have been built to keep us away from gross sickly things
and now it seems overextended.
And so it seems as if if it fires it over fires and in a way that actually might
make our moral judgments,
we might have to be careful in a way that we,
we don't necessarily have to be careful for some other emotions.
So not let discuss,
kind of go,
uh,
on,
on harness.
Just kind of go wild.
Right.
And one example I like to give people is,
um,
you know,
just because something is disgusting doesn't mean that it's wrong.
So for instance,
I find it very disgusting to,
uh,
to pick your nose,
right?
I think everybody probably find that,
discuss it,
but nobody goes around saying down with nose picking.
Um,
and so when,
when you're using discussed as the sole as the sole measure of whether or not
you think something is wrong,
I think you really need to kind of check yourself and say,
oh look,
there's a lot of,
lot of really disgusting things.
But,
but are,
is it necessarily true that they're wrong?
And what we find is that what may be going on is it some people are more likely
to use,
discussed as input into their moral judgment than others.
And so while everybody might be disgusted,
say a particular sexual acts,
some people stop at the disgust and say,
well that has nothing to do with what I believe about whether you ought to be
allowed to do that.
But some people actually find it as a perfectly reasonable thing to use their
disgust as input.
So you've also found that discuss influences really important,
you know,
health care related behaviors such as deciding to go for a cancer screening or
to avoid it.
Right.
So what impact you think,
discuss,
can actually have on our own health and sort of public health policy?
Yeah,
this is an interesting,
uh,
an interesting feature of disgust that my colleague Nathan Considine,
who is actually a clinical health psychologist was interested in.
I hadn't given it much thought,
but the truth of the matter is when you have a disease,
it's easy to be disgusted at yourself.
Um,
and so a lot of these health health behaviors require us to go to the doctor and
do things like provide stool samples or you're in samples or show the doctor
that disgusting part of your body that you've been embarrassed to show anybody
else.
And that given the power of disgust,
you know,
I've said a few times now,
it's a strong,
it's a strong avoidance response when you feel disgust for yourself.
Um,
Eh,
you are ashamed to show the doctor this.
This is a very powerful motivation that keeps people away from going to the
doctor.
So there are all kinds of,
of uh,
uh,
people who for instance,
have a growth that goes completely unchecked.
And by the time they go to the doctor,
the doctor's like,
why haven't you come in earlier?
And the truth is that they were,
they were afraid to or ashamed or disgusted by themselves.
And so part of what I think needs to be done is,
is I think people don't realize that doctors in fact are very,
very well trained in avoiding discussed for that particular domain.
And so,
uh,
and so one of the,
the health messages when we're trying to convince people to engage in,
in these positive health behaviors like screening behaviors,
we need to tell them,
look,
doctor seen a lot grosser than that.
Right?
That's right.
I'm sure they have.
And maybe you're the one person,
right?
Well,
I think anybody who browses the Internet for a sufficient period of time has
probably seen just as many gross things as I have.
What do you think then is in the store for the future study of emotion?
What's that?
It's,
it's interesting.
I,
uh,
when I started studying emotion,
it seemed like a fairly novel thing.
So the history of the study of emotion and psychology is kind of interesting.
So we had some very,
very powerful early,
uh,
early research and then,
and then we just started ignoring it for a while and then there was this
explosion of research and emotion that that was exciting.
And,
um,
and I think a lot of the reason that there was this explosion was because of an
increased availability of methods to study emotion.
There.
There are more and more methods that psychologists can use.
Um,
and that hasn't seem to stop.
So my fear was always like this would,
it would ebb and flow in that,
that we might sort of lose interest in emotion,
but I don't think that's happening.
I think with increased methods more,
we're learning more and more about what emotions are and what they do.
And so I'm actually really optimistic about the future.
I mean,
now nowadays we can buy devices for a couple of hundred dollars that are
portable,
that can measure your physiological reactions.
Um,
throughout the day.
We couldn't do that even when I was in graduate school.
It was,
which was a year ago June,
that would have cost us thousands and thousands of dollars.
And so,
so there's nothing to stop us from.
And even with Internet data collection,
even if you're talking about just shirt,
sheer,
subjective emotional responses,
um,
it's,
it's just becoming easier and easier to study emotion.
So I think that the big task before us won't be to,
to gather data.
It will be to make sense of the overwhelming amount of data that we have.
So we need,
we need young,
good emotion theorists to try to make sense of what's going on in these data.
And I hope that that's,
that's,
that's actually what happens in the next 10 years.
People who are smarter than you and I who are currently in graduate school will
come along and make some sense of it all still in Grad school.
Well,
speaking of the students then,
sort of what advice would you give Grad students or younger students,
people may be thinking about studying emotion?
What,
what advice would you give for them as they think about embarking in this,
you know,
uncharted terrain.
Yeah.
The,
the biggest piece of advice I have is don't lose your curiosity,
your broad curiosity.
Um,
because if we're really going to make progress,
we need students who are interested,
intrinsically interested in the topic such that they will read,
they will learn about every everything.
Emotion,
as you know,
is one of the most truly interdisciplinary topics in psycho.
I mean,
psychology is already touches on so many other fields,
but emotion in particular,
you can read a evolutionary biology,
genetics,
you can read sociology,
you can read the philosophy of emotion.
And there's this problem that when when students come into Grad school,
we have to get them narrow.
You come in with all of these broad interests and you're forced to go narrow or
in there,
you know,
by the time you're done,
your dissertation is like,
you know,
on the effects of x on y when Z is,
is in population,
you know,
and it's,
it becomes such a narrow,
narrow topic that that has the possibility of killing peoples breadth.
And so,
so don't lose sight of the fact that this is a truly deep and interesting and
broad question and read,
read whatever floats your boat.
That has to do with the topic.
You know,
if you read robotics,
you can learn about emotion.
Don't,
don't stop doing that.
Um,
and,
and for God's sakes,
don't do anything that you don't feel any intrinsic interest in.
They will never pay you enough to study something that you don't want to study
just because it's the hot or popular topic.
Well,
thanks for talking with us today,
David.
Um,
this concludes our experts and emotion interview with Dr. David Pizarro from
Cornell University.